Film Courage: I’m sure you are asked about
this scene constantly, but the interrogation
scene from MENACE II SOCIETY?
I know you’ve probably been asked this question
so much, but if you can just take us back
to that day during this scene, what was it
like for you?
Bill Duke, Actor/Filmmaker/Author: I’d just
finished doing a film I think it was in Canada
and acting in a film.
I rushed back and at the same day that I came
in, I had to be on the set…the Hughes Brothers
and I just loved their work.
I liked who they were.
I read the script and I loved it.
It was only one scene and it’s like the
way they set it up got me immediately into
the mood because the room was dark except
there were three spotlights, one on the young
boy, one on the middle of the table where
the was and once on myself.
Everything else was in shadow.
And the police had brought this young man
into this place to intimidate him into telling
the truth and so he was sitting there really
nervous, you know?
He thought he was smarter than everybody in
the room and so when I questioned him it was
like I first brought the gun in, put it on
the table and turned it toward him but said
to him “You are not necessarily getting
out of here alive.
There’s nothing you can do about it.
What are you going to do?
We can all say that you reached for the and
we defended ourselves and shot you.”
We didn’t say those words we just went…[motions
to turning the gun around].
That was it, that said it.
I saw that and it was like “Oh boy, okay.”
And I started asking questions about was he
there and he said “No” And he said “You
bought the beer here” and you brought the
beer here.
And that’s when his hands start shaking.
And that’s when I knew that I had him.
And
that little thought they were so smart but
they were so stupid.
And it was a feeling of joy when I said to
him “You know something…you know you done
f*cked up don’t you?”
“No, no, no…”
“No, no, no, no, no…you know you done
f*cked up right?”
Here’s what’s crazy, I was in Brussels
in Belgium about five or six months ago acting
in a film with Nicholas Cage called MANDY
right?
I’m sitting in a restaurant eating food
by myself, this young Belgium kid comes up
to me and says “Excuse me sir but you know
you done f*cked up right?”
I laughed so hard.
No matter what country I go to, I’ve made
a lot of films as an actor and director and
the line that is said to me the most around
the world no matter what city I go to and
you know something by young kids, that’s
what’s amazing to me.
They’ve all seen that picture.
I don’t know how they see it.
They see it and they all repeat that line.
So yes, it’s interesting.
Film Courage: How has this impacted your life?
I’m sure it’s got to feel good that they’re
seeing your work.
At the same time, maybe you’re surprised
that they are young kids seeing this film
from all walks of life?
What does that do to someone?
Bill: Well, it means you did a good job because
you impacted them in that way?
I also wish there was more than they remember
you for than just a line?
You’re appreciate that they’ve seen your
work and appreciate what you’ve done and
that’s always good because I’m very self-critical
of my work and so when someone affirms that
what I’ve done has impacted them, that’s
very rewarding, that’s very rewarding.
Because they don’t have to be kind, they
don’t have to come up to you, they don’t
have to but they do.
At a certain age you’d think they’d forgotten
about you but they haven’t, especially young
people do it from different countries.